peut-être mais il ya des filles ont une
ribambelle tout autour de mes semelles
je me sens id les
gdg je voudrais une légende assez léger
mieux de les caresser
bonsoir difficile de parler de lui au
passé ils étaient l'inoubliable
interprète de battling joe fait des
feuilles mortes celui de l'aveu ou du
milliardaire ils montrent ans est décédé
cet après midi d'un infarctus à l'âge de
70 ans avant de voir ensemble de
nombreuses réactions suscitées par sa
disparition brutale
retour sur le parcours de ce fils
d'immigré devenu l'un des plus grands
artistes français michel vial qui sait
on va
pour personne
sa vie ressemble à un roman et il avait
fait de sa carrière une légende née il y
à 70 ans en toscane fils d'un maçon
italien
yves montand avait émigré dans les
années 30 en france avec sa famille pour
fuir le fascisme après avoir été libre
heures coiffeur et manoeuvre il était
monté pour la première fois sur scène à
marseille en 1938 la chanson c'est
l'étincelle d'une carrière éblouissante
qui fera de lui l'égal des plus grands
stars de ce siècle chanteur mais aussi
comédien il débute véritablement en 1944
au théâtre de l'étoile grâce à edith
piaf
la première femme exceptionnelle d'une
ville qui en comptera beaucoup
désormais il chante sur toutes les
scènes du monde tandis que le cinéma la
capa il tourne avec les plus grands aux
côtés des plus grands difficile en effet
d'oublier ses prestations du salaire de
la peur de l'aveu de z de césar et
rosalie ou de jean de florette entre
autres en 1949 il rencontre simone
signoret l'actrice déjà mythique de
casque d'or avec elle il vivra 35 années
d'une passion à la fois orageuse étendre
une étonnante complicité intellectuelle
qui les conduira à partager tous les
combats pour l'homme malgré le relatif
échec de ces deux derniers films trois
places pour le 26 et netchaïev est de
retour d'yves montand avait de nombreux
projets il s'était remarié il y a quatre
ans il était le père d'un petit valentin
il terminait un film avec jean jacques
beineix il avait même fixé pour mes 92
son retour sur scène à bercy
la mort l'a donc surprise en pleine
activité pratiquement sous la lumière
des projecteurs qui ne l'avait pas
quitté depuis près de 60 ans mais bien
moi ce que je préfère c'est louis jean
gars il évacue tout appris le corps
d'yves montand doit être transporté ce
soir à paris le comédien est décédé donc
je vous le disais à l'âge de 70 ans à
l'hôpital de senlis dans l'oise
dominique dumas vous êtes place dauphine
une place sur la qualif montant a
longtemps résidé quelles sont les
réactions autour de vous ce soir alors
effectivement laurence ici aucun zappé
la zoophilie à beaucoup de monde
beaucoup de curieux certes mais aussi
beaucoup de nostalgiques du montant
beaucoup d'admirateurs également
beaucoup de journalistes qui viennent
d'arriver
alors je peux vous dire en toute
dernière information qu'on vient
d'apprendre que le convoi mortuaire
depuis senlis allait partir il est même
déjà partie et on attend
vraisemblablement cette voiture
mortuaires aux alentours de 21h si mes
calculs sont bien ici au 15 de la place
dauphine
les récents gains sur sont des réactions
souvent attristé il ya même des jeunes
qui sont là pour témoigner leur
admiration envers un chanteur qui n'ont
pas forcément connus très bien merci
dominique une nouvelle à laquelle
l'homme de la rue bien sûr a bien du mal
à croire ce soir réactions recueillies
donc ce soir à paris par caroline since
et jean jacques lé deuil dans les
cinémas les gens apprennent la nouvelle
avec stupeur l'homme semble est immortel
et promet pas moins bien point de mourir
cet après midi pas possible
mais beaucoup la façon dont ils
chantaient en scène voilà donc après un
excellent souvenir
les textiles pour vous d'être pompier
le chanteur les opportunistes sur le
plan politique on a quelqu'un
d'important dans le domaine de la
chanson même charme d'un excellent
comedia
enfin c'était important
j'ai 24 ans et disons que il
représentait une certaine qualité de la
chanson française du passé place
dauphine les curieux commencent à
affluer devant son domicile parisien
celui qu'il avait partagé avec simone
signoret montant n'était pas une star
inapprochable pour ses voisins il
restera l'homme au grand coeur il était
un homme très sympa et généreux et puis
je gémis sur les tanks marines la place
dauphine a perdu son couple le plus
célèbre la vie n'y sera plus tout à fait
comme avant ils vont longtemps de son
vrai nom ivo livi devait bientôt renouer
avec la chanson il devait se produire au
palais omnisports de bercy en mai
prochain
il tournait actuellement dans le nouveau
film de jean jacques beineix sa
disparition en deuil le monde artistique
la réaction ce soir de michel maure
gants au micro de france info
à chaud je dois dire que quand je les ai
entendu ça à la radio shack équitable en
séquences assez petit garçon qui verra
pas son père
désespérant j'ai tourné avec lui et je
l'aimais beaucoup
je l'avais bien c'est quelqu'un de très
agréable d'être echard monde
le drôle moi j'ai adoré j'ai adoré ce
qu'il a fait toutes ces années
merveilleuses de chansons de cette voie
que j'aime toujours d'ailleurs que je
continue à aimer
il avait un don pour le choix de ses
chansons yves montand chanteur
affectionnez particulièrement une salle
dans paris l'olympia qui lui a valu ses
premiers succès dans la capitale en 1981
il était resté quatre mois à la fiche
témoignage de paul est qu catrice
l'épousé de bruno coquatrix l'homme qui
a fait d'elle un piia oled coquatrix
venir le plus marquant pour moi c'était
son son perfectionnisme c'est la façon
dont ils se préparaient la façon dont y
régler la chaux dans le moindre détail
est rien passé sont autrement car ses
mains quand le rideau s'ouvre est il y
avait son chapeau qui était sur le micro
et bien le chapeau c'est lui même qui
venait tous les jours le met sur le
micro il fallait pas que ce soit comme
ça
ou comme ça a failli ce soir comme ça
moi personnellement je les ai vus à
marseille pour la première fois quand il
chantait habillé en cow boy
alors bon il ya eu on sépare vue pendant
les quelques années de la guerre et puis
on s'est retrouvé tout de suite après
pour ne pas vraiment ce qui t'est jamais
puisque j'étais lié aussi avec beaucoup
d'affection à simone et voilà quand mon
mari est mort il est mort ça s'est su
dans la nuit le lendemain matin à 8
heures ils étaient là je sais même pas
s'ils n'étaient pas 7h30 enfin il a été
là à la première heure
il m'a pris dans ses bras et m'a dit une
chose qui compte beaucoup aujourd'hui
il m'a dit ne sois pas triste il est
parti comme on voudrait tous partir
finalement c'est parti comme ça lui
aussi yves montand chanteurs comédiens
sommes engagés dans la vie comme dans
ses films
impossible pour lui de
vers son destin en solitaire la vie
n'aurait plus de sens disait-il
lb vais pas mentir trace pendant les
grandes étapes de son engagement un
acteur un homme engagé dans l'aveu yves
montand dénoncé le totalitarisme
communiste un système qu'il a pourtant
soutenu un parti le pc dans le sillage
duquel il a longtemps évolué avec simone
signoret sa femme opposition franquisme
au colonialisme à la guerre d'algérie
mais les chats russe à budapest en 56
marque la rupture
ce sera ensuite l'écrasement du
printemps de prague puis l'invasion de
l'afghanistan
dès lors yves montand n'aura de cesse de
mettre en garde l'occident contre ce
qu'ils appellent le double jeu
soviétique
cessons d'être du puits à la limite
lâche faisons respecter les accords
d'helsinki ou alors ne soyons pas
complices par mon silence et nous
jérémiades des notions nous mêmes cette
sinistre face elle a déjà que trop duré
zombie zombie les frères de l'ouest du
fort mais néanmoins naïf et crédule
américain ne cédons pas restons éveillés
fort ferme et vigilant solidarité et
valaisanne les boat people vietnamiens
les dissidents chinois après le bain de
sang de la place tiananmen
yves montand épouse le combat des droits
de l'homme
son dernier engagement anne août dernier
lorsque le putsch de moscou fait
vaciller un instant la démocratie
naissante en union soviétique d'yves
montand restera l'image d'un homme
sincère qui n'a pas eu peur de revenir
sur ses convictions
lorsque sa conscience le lui dicter
premières réactions politiques et celle
de valéry giscard d'estaing
je vous propose de l'écouter tout de
suite en son attachement à la gauche et
même à la gauche extrême c'était le
sentiment de la souffrance et de
l'injustice quand il a vu que finalement
il y avait une manipulation et un usage
de la souffrance et d'injustice et que
finalement les sociétés en question
était très cruel et très dur notamment
pour telle ou telle minorité il a
complètement changé d'attitude et donc
je les ai vus depuis une dizaine
d'années j'ai rencontré
plusieurs reprises pour des repas d'amis
et j'avais pour lui je dois dire
ressenti beaucoup d'affection parce que
j'avais découvert au delà du talent la
très grande générosité la très grande
simplicité de l'homme
henry chapier que va-t-il rester d'yves
montand qu'est ce que les français vont
d'abord regretté aujourd'hui mais je
crois que c'était notre conscience et
depuis quelques années on s'en est
aperçu les prises de position d'abord
évidemment l'image de la ve il faut
aussi se souvenir de l'artiste mais il
n'était pas que cela c'est-à-dire qu'on
peut pas les dissocier l'acteur engagé
on ne peut pas le dissocier de l'homme
pour lui la vie était un tout
le mét il faisait un grand professionnel
mais en même temps il nous disait que ce
que l'on faisait n'avait d'importance
que si on avait la foi en quelque chose
et là dernièrement et ses propos n'ont
pas encore paru il avait l'habitude de
dire
mais enfin on voulait que l'aide soit
libéré et à présent referme les
frontières ce sont des propos que
certains témoins ont entendu ils n'ont
pas paru encore c'était ya trois
semaines yves montand évidemment dans
une réunion privée mais il allait
préparer là dessus probablement une de
ces tribunes pour nous rappeler qu'il
faut accueillir ceux qui veulent venir
et que nous devons avoir un idéal et
c'est cela qui nous restera l'absence de
cette fois de cette voie qui nous dit où
aller en quelque sorte
et sur cette idée d'engagement c'est
aussi le couple qu'il formait avec
simone signoret a bien entendu ils ont
traversé toutes les épreuves et
heureusement pour elle et pour lui ils
sont revenus sur l'illusion communiste à
temps et ils ont beaucoup contribué
si vous voulez je conclurai pas une
chose ils sont le premier exemple en
france d'un acteur trainer d'opinion et
yves montand avaient beaucoup
d'importance on avait même dit un jour
qu'il allait se présenter à la
présidence de la république
ce n'était pas exact mais il manque et
ce qui manquera c'est ce genre de voix
et de conviction qui lave et puis être
père à 68 ans était aussi un sacré
engagement évidemment évidemment c'est
certainement un don du ciel
et probablement qui ne sera pas déçu et
nous non plus merci henri voilà seul que
l'on pouvait dire ce soir sur la
disparition d'yves montand
nous y reviendrons longuement bien sûr
dans notre édition de soir 3 l'actualité
est toujours marquée par la grogne
sociale nouvel épisode de la colère des
agriculteurs ce matin avec de violents
affrontements entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre à auch dans le gers
reportage de josiane mage et serge
ryberg tomates et pneus brûlés ont
accompagné ce matin la visite du
ministre de l'éducation lionel jospin à
auch 300 agriculteurs de la fdsea du cdg
à se sont rassemblés à l'entrée de l'iut
ceinturés par les forces de l'ordre
alors que le ministre pendant c'est son
allocution à l'intérieur du bâtiment
universitaire dehors agriculteurs et
forces de l'ordre se sont affrontés
bilan cinq blessés trois chez les
agriculteurs de chez les crs
un agriculteur a dû être hospitalisée
pour traumatisme crânien une affaire
politique et non syndical pour lionel
jospin
je crois qu'il faut il faut justement le
dialogue il ya des petits bouchons
estivaux politisé
quand même des candidats aux élections
paroisse et qui
alors ils sont bons alors que ce même
jour le ministre a reçu une délégation
d'agriculteurs du mode s attendant en
vain celle de la fdsea route de tarbes
toulouse agen et mont-de-marsan ont été
bloqués à deux kilomètres autour
d'offres à vous couper en travers de la
route fut moins enflammés ont formé des
barrages la jospin est passé outre par
l'hélicoptère pour rejoindre dit que un
sac où l'attendait cette fois plus de
500 militants du ps la grande pagaille
du ciel la grève engagée jeudi soir par
les électroniciens de l'aviation civile
a encore perturbé aujourd'hui le trafic
aérien à orly et roissy encombré retard
également dans de nombreux dans de
nombreuses villes en province le point
tout site avec dominique d'humains
ambiance calme à l'aéroport d'orly-ouest
les passagers ne s'impatientent plus
tous les vols au départ de paris ont été
maintenus malgré quelques retards
d'environ un quart d'heure pour la
bretagne notamment et le languedoc le
conflit des électroniciens du ciel doit
durer en principe jusqu'à mercredi une
trentaine sur une cinquantaine de ses
techniciens chargés de la maintenance
des ordinateurs est toujours en grève
mais le ministère des transports a
demandé de reprendre le travail tout en
continuant à se déclarer grévistes cela
explique le retour à la normale il reste
à connaître les résultats de l' enquête
pourquoi cette cascade d'ordinateurs en
pagne coïncidant avec la grève
les aéroports de province ont été
également perturbée notamment la
provence côte d'azur et la bretagne
cela explique les avions atterrissant à
orly avec encore une heure et demie de
retard
si vous êtes en région parisienne et si
vous attendez quelqu'un ce soir à orly
soyez patient il doit normalement
arriver
l'udf clarifie sa position à l'égard du
front national il n'y aura pas
d'alliance avec l'extrême droite
la fédération réunis pour la première
fois ce week end à paris les 1600
membres de son tout nouveau comité
national objectif s'affirmer comme la
première force de l'opposition
reportage michel mr le maire et
marie-hélène roque temps
les deux faces de l'udf aujourd'hui à la
défense symbolisée par son nouveau logo
côté pile un président valéry giscard
d'estaing réélu sans surprise avec tout
même près de 14% des voix qui ne se sont
pas portés sur son nom de nouveaux
statuts qui vont permettre à la base de
mieux s'exprimer et à l'udf de dépasser
le stade du simple cartel électoral
et puis des alliances clarifier avec la
condamnation catégorique de tout accord
avec l'extrême droite
mais côté face le grain de sable un beau
tollé suscité par zaki et unionistes
jusqu'au bout faisait remarquer qu'il
était paradoxal d'être où vit dans une
formation et d'avoir des groupes séparés
dans les différentes assemblées l'union
l'intérieur de moi qu'il faut bien y
aller on ne veut pas travailler sur le
terrain je dois parlementaire quand il
ya une chose qui me navre c'est d'avoir
deux groupes de l'assemblée nationale
qui en plus de rendre votre exactement
la même chose aujourd'hui
il faut garder le site cette richesse
que la diversité du dr
et je crois que le groupe union du
centre un rôle à jouer dans la
préparation de ces élections où il
s'agit de mobiliser le plus grand nombre
de français
ne brûlons pas les étapes répondent donc
les centristes cet épisode montre le
chemin qu'il reste encore à parcourir à
l'udf pour la quête et la réussite de
l'éternel saint graal de la politique
l'unité dans la diversité
l'actualité à l'étranger plus de quatre
mois de crise en yougoslavie et la
situation s'envenime la présidence
yougoslave réduite aux blocs serbe
demande l'envoi d'urgence des troupes de
l'onu en croatie une république toujours
en proie de violents combats vue cover
assiégée depuis 80 jours a bien du mal à
résister philippe pisteurs
les chars de l'armée fédérale fonçant
sur vue kovar le symbole de la
résistance croate sur le point de tomber
après plus de 80 jours de siège
hier ils avançaient que le combat final
était engagé aujourd'hui les fédéraux
avancent dans le centre de la ville ils
auraient pris le contrôle d'un quartier
stratégique des unités spécialisées dans
les combats de rue ont été dépêchés sur
place
la croatie à feu et à sang aux irec
karlovac nova gradisca par tous les
combats des de l'adriatique la marine
fédéral a repris ses bombardements hier
soir et ce matin sur dubrovnik
la cité médiévale coupés du monde depuis
40 jours une intensification des combats
alors que les forces croates refusent de
déposer les armes et de céder à
l'ultimatum fédéral pourtant malgré
l'offensive fédérale sur le terrain coup
de théâtre cet après midi la présidence
suguenot cela dominé par les serbes
demande à l'onu l'envoi d'urgence d'une
force de maintien de la paix en prend
assise pour mettre fin aux combats appel
contradictoires mais qui s'explique
certainement par la décision de george
bush cet après midi à la et d'imposer
des sanctions à la yougoslavie suivant
ainsi l'exemple européen
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
consacrée largement bien sûr à la
disparition d'yves montand
je vous rappelle que le comédien est
décédé cet après midi d'un infarctus à
l'âge de 70 ans
dernière réaction à l'instant celle de
jack lang
la nouvelle de la disparition d'yves
montand me bouleverse déclare le
ministre de la culture
voilà je vous retrouve à 22h40 pour soir
3 avec bien sûr d'autres réactions
on se quitte en chansons avec le dernier
passage d'yves montand à l'olympia
c'était en 1980 quand voir mais
simplement pour voir
les belles boutiques sur les avenues et
firent sourire gracieux avec des
promesses malézieux l'écrire de journaux
du soir les enfants qui jouent dans les
secours
à ce que la lui peut-être mais il ya des
filles ont une ribambelle de tours
2 mai
et semaine